[Music]
spacex's starlink project is an internet
constellation that will provide the
world with low-cost high-performance
internet
around the world but it's not just about
letting you scroll tik-tok for a cheaper
monthly data plan
starlink is going to change global
politics and businesses
in several ways in addition to giving
you cheaper monthly data packs of course
nearly 40 percent of the world still
doesn't have stable access to the
internet
that's about 12 times the population of
the united states
for a large number of them it's because
they don't have the infrastructure to
get online
but all that is about to change welcome
back to our channel
before we dive in make sure you
subscribe and hit the bell icon
so you are notified when we upload a new
video first things first
exactly how fast will the internet be
when starlink is up
estimates say 40 times faster than
today's high-speed internet in america
and it will get faster once the entire
constellation is complete
the satellites will use lasers to
communicate with each other so there's
lower latency over
long distances light travels faster
through space compared to fiber optic
cables on earth
basically you'll be able to play games
watch movies in high def
and do everything you want to do without
even thinking about speed
starlink will place 2 000 small
satellites into orbit by the end of 2021
and the ultimate goal is to put 30 000
of them into space
currently the satellite internet that we
have uses a large spacecraft that orbits
236 miles above a particular spot on the
earth but at that distance
there are major time delays in sending
and receiving data
by being closer to the planet and
networking together starlink satellites
will carry large amounts of information
quickly
to any point on the earth even over
oceans and hard to reach places where
fiber optic cables
can't be laid down according to elon
musk the starlink network would be able
to provide minor coverage after 400
spacecraft are deployed
and moderate coverage at 800 and as it
brings globalized internet access
the fundamental cultural makeup of the
internet is bound to transform
it only makes sense a massive influx of
users will flood the digital network
and we will see a wave of cultural
change to digital communities and the
formation of new digital ecosystems
not to mention how access to the
internet will provide new forms of
prosperity
to billions of people and disrupt the
traditional power dynamics of the world
right now a little under half of 7.8
billion people
don't get regular internet access these
tend to be people from lower income
and non-english speaking regions of the
world plus the governments of many
countries limit their residence access
to the internet
paranoid governments are increasingly
blocking the flow of information in
certain countries
and it is a disturbing trend for such a
liberating technology
despite this lack of access there does
exist an appetite for connectivity
before we dig into starlink it's
important to understand the state of the
internet today
our world's internet traffic is
dependent on a small number of fiber
optic cables
more of which are running along the
bottoms of our oceans which makes them
vulnerable they can be disrupted by
earthquakes and anchors
sharks could chew on them in one case a
vietnamese fisherman scavenging for
copper wire pulled up
miles of fiber optic cable disrupting
one of only two lines connecting the
country to the outside world
but the real issue is when these cables
cross into a country's border
because it's here at the choke point of
information that governments gain
control
and unsurprisingly china comes in last
for internet freedom
not only do they ban gmail instagram
youtube
facebook and many other services they
also use the internet to spy on their
citizens
and punish them for what seems harmless
sadly this special case is now becoming
the norm for most governments
countries like brazil and india which
have huge populations
are losing internet freedom but the good
news is technology
always finds a way and in this case the
solution
is starlink they're making their
innovations user-friendly so all you
have to do is plug a medium pizza sized
box into the wall and point the antenna
at the sky
a few seconds later you have high-speed
internet this connection would even
evade china's firewall and attempts to
control information
now as starlink comes online and makes
access possible for nearly 4 billion
people
we can expect the makeup of the internet
to change that includes the language and
cultural norms of digital communities
not to mention more business
opportunities more individuals in these
countries can start small businesses
and existing entrepreneurs will now ask
questions about services they can offer
the new users
in low access areas there is a clear
lack of an it industry or i.t skills
we can expect to see growth and easy to
access e-learning platforms
platforms like skillshare and khan
academy these platforms will be mobile
friendly and focus on core business
skills like communication
marketing product design and more there
will even be opportunities to provide
training in online security and privacy
tools
proper online banking habits avoiding
scams and the importance of strong
passwords
but more importantly increased internet
access would turn the global labor wage
dynamic over on its head
people in low-income regions will find a
world of opportunities to sell their
talent online
and businesses in developed countries
will have a host of new digital services
to choose from
on the other hand though we do risk
workers in these developed countries
experience wage disruption
and losing their employment it's going
to be great for companies that want to
save money
but not so good for the labor economy on
the bright side
there is an opportunity to educate newly
online people on how to become
financially independent by learning to
utilize the full value of the internet
the internet has created so much wealth
and prosperity that it now represents a
powerful opportunity for new users to
build a stable
and more resilient life the bottom line
is that whether you already have access
to the internet or not
the starlink program will change how you
browse and the information you find on
the internet
it's important to keep track of this
development because it's going to impact
everyone on the planet in some way but
starlink isn't entirely invincible
there are ways the governments could get
around new internet freedom if they
wanted to they could ban the antennas
for example
but remember how we said technology
finds a way soon enough
the starlink home box would get smaller
and the antennas would shrink further in
size and with 3d printing now building
everything from airplane parts to whole
buildings
who's going to stop someone from making
a tiny antenna in their bedroom in the
course of a few hours
well there is another way governments
could thwart starlink which is the more
likely option
they will tell the company and its
founder elon musk to turn off the
satellites hovering over their space
or face consequences that range from
embargoing his other businesses
to just shooting at satellites out of
the sky sounds easy enough
but the problem with governments banning
antennas and shooting missiles at low
orbit satellites is that it raises the
cost of internet censorship
instead of simply turning off access at
the choke point of a fiber optic cable
they will now have to hunt down citizens
who have dishes
suffer the loss of businesses with some
of the world's most successful companies
or risk outright war
and anything that raises the cost of
censorship is a bad thing for
governments
and a good thing for their citizens
starlink is already beta testing serving
over ten thousand customers and they
have over seven hundred thousand
applicants waiting to try the service
themselves
soon enough starlink will expand to the
rest of the us and canada
they have asked the federal
communications commission for permission
to deploy up to five million user
terminals which they ironically call
dishy mcflatface it receives
transmissions from starlink's low earth
orbit satellites
the service will cost you between 50 and
80 a month and the one-time fee for the
user terminal is said to be 499
when a huge company like spacex sees
success in a particular field and gains
media attention for it
other companies are bound to follow
there is now a race to dominate space as
amazon comes in with a 10 billion dollar
plan
for 3 236 satellites they would be
joining telesat
a venture backed by the canadian
government but of course starlink is
going to get there first
even if elon musk tends to give
ambitious timelines for his projects
spacex is already deploying satellites
at an insane rate
and their new facility in texas is only
going to speed things up further
they expect to have almost global
coverage by next year which is great for
us
think you might subscribe to starlink
for 80 bucks a month is that too much
let us know what you think in the
comments below if you like this video
make sure to give us a like and check
out more videos like it on the simply
tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time